from a health and wellness perspective
testosterone is sinking and I think the
hormonal effects of that are actually
creating you know secondary personality
changes in men that are unfavorable and
that's why I think so many men by the
way are single when you say there's this
generation of men that are sexless yeah
you're unattractive to women because
your testosterone is shrinking you're
less masculine you read as less able to
defend and protect your family you read
as less competent you read like somebody
who's going to be crying with a big old
you know my Ben and Jerry's joke I say
all the time a big old carton of Ben and
Jerry is when the notebook's on and
that's women aren't looking for that
laughs